wait a minute we were just talking about
kerry washington screaming
we were just talking about her skating
so you didn't put on skates
i didn't say that you didn't i just said
i'm not that many people because i
didn't mean one of them i don't want to
be one of the people to fall i'm really
happy she's here right now because i'm
gonna put issa on black okay what does a
girl have to do to get invited on some
yachts i said the same thing what does
the homie have to do you gotta turn it
off
how do we get on issa's yacht before
yacht first of all the prerequisites are
you have to uh you have to throw ass
are you prepared
drink water um and you have to um
no plus ones
no plus ones for real
sorry
okay so we'll each come on our own it's
a big night for you all the way around
black lady sketch show you you let me my
show go and you know i'm not happy with
you about that i kind of want to beef
with you but i didn't
listen i actually i hate endings of
series i actually really dug the ending
of insecure i i i was like okay she did
us all right she didn't do us dirty she
did not do us dirty
now i want to know what shows did you
dirty but is that a different
conversation oh i can tell seinfeld get
me dirty
sopranos did me real dirty
real real dirty
um fresh prince kind of did me dirty
back in the day at the house he was back
at that moment
and then carlton running out with his
pants well i mean i guess that was a
good moment it was a great ending and
when you think back do you do you still
have pinch me moments or do you are you
one of those like nah let's let's get
this i'm ready for the next thing here
we go both when i have endings i
definitely have pinch me moments but
it's like with so much of our work it
feels ongoing right so sometimes i'm
just like i forget to put my head up but
with that with insecure and especially
this last year i've really taken a lot
of time to be like wow all this happened
i cannot believe it like being at the
emmys for the first time like five years
ago
and you know now it's still like
nerve-wracking but it's like oh i've
experienced this before there's so many
things like that where i'm like i can't
believe so much has happened in just
five years and congratulations late news
rap just got renewed for season two
thank you so much i'm so excited to do a
second season of this show like our cast
is incredible and
i'm really really really excited about
the stories that we get to sell how does
your brain work
honestly because i sit there and
everything and sometimes how's she come
up with this stuff i sound like a
compliment this doesn't know what it is
it's the biggest i'm like hell she cut
that like how does your brain even work
i don't know i've been trying to figure
that out honestly you tell me
well i can tell you one thing you are
black barbie black barbie's coming to
our screens what was that experience
like it was amazing i cannot confirm or
deny that i am black barbie okay and i'm
in the barbie movie and it was the best
experience no lie i have ever had on a
set really it was so much fun and i love
greta i love margot like it was just a
great experience i know i think i read
somewhere where you were saying i never
pictured that for me
never you know what i'm saying i would
have never pictured that for me at all
to be in a barbie movie i played with
barbies but i didn't see myself like in
that world in any way so it was it was
just exciting
well you know i'm jealous because there
is a nichelle barbie
and i have her but i ain't never been in
a barbie movie there's a nichelle bar
there is a and she's a journalist
so it's clearly they bit your whole life
you know what i'm saying come on mattel
patel you're getting sued she's a
journalist she's a print journalist and
she wears a big curly puff on her head
it's me is he not claiming that where is
that listen i have her
i own her
eyes she don't have my eyes but she does
wear a big curly puff on her head and
she wears overalls that's the nichelle
barbie that's it